does the internet really offer better
deals apparently not in the short term
because online prices in the us rose 2.1
in august from july that's according to
the adobe digital price index which
tracks data based on visits to retail
websites now compared with a year ago
online prices rose four tenths of one
percent in august marking a comeback for
inflation from the drop seen in july
which had raised hopes that prices in
the digital economy peaked the august
data now show otherwise so what's
driving the latest increase
food online grocery prices jumped 14.1
percent from a year ago a record gain
and the 31st straight month of advances
while prices in the largest category
electronics fell 10 from last year along
with groceries adobe says strong
consumer demand will keep prices
elevated for categories like pet
products and other consumer staples
contrast this with the overall economy
where government data show consumer
prices are little changed on a
month-to-month basis and up around eight
percent on an annual basis even after
the pandemic only about 15 percent of
retail spending in the us is done online
you